[Music]
foreign
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studio this is the
Ramsey Show it's where we talk with you
about your life specifically your money
your relationships and your work in all
three of those areas are absolutely tied
together and if you're not winning in
one of those areas I promise you this
you're losing in the other areas and we
want to give you some practical steps so
that you have a clear path forward hope
filled advice I'm Ken Coleman he is Dr
John deloney we're here together for you
it is a free phone call Triple eight
eight two five five two two five triple
eight eight two five five two two five
now listen I gotta call this out for
those of you that are long time
listeners new listeners you're going hey
this is uh this really is more than just
a money show and you got two non-money
experts today so take the advice uh with
uh shall we say a light grip John sell
the truck then we'll just go ahead and
say that's what we're gonna say we're
going to say we're going to say no debt
and we're gonna give you your basic
money advice but I do want you to take
advantage of this opportunity John and I
uh we get the awesome privilege to
travel together all around the country
and we do a kind of a pre-event
free-for-all where we sit together on a
stage at Building Wealth live and we
take people's questions around
relationships and mental health and work
and John we find many times at those
events that we end up both answering
it's all together questions it's all
braided together so uh mental health
struggling hey here's one how about
taking uh John and I for a spin on toxic
workplaces you're in a toxic work
environment those are fun for us because
they do involve both of our Vantage
points and uh so whatever your money
question your relationship question
anxiety questions mental health work all
of it together John and I are here so
let's go Blake is going to start us off
in Madison Wisconsin Blake how can we
help
how's it going guys man we're having a
blast what's going on with you today
uh I'm starting to turn my life around
here uh this New Year's been a big big
start in the right direction
but right now I'm I'm back from college
um I'm a coving addict and I'm not sure
exactly what I want to do I have so many
ideas in my head for a career okay and
I'm just like I gotta make sure I'm
doing the right thing here what's the
nature of your addiction brother
oh
sorry I don't know if you could hear
that that was an alarm
um no I didn't hear it
uh my addiction was alcohol and
everything on my phone TV I'll say
everything okay food so what uh what
what what flip the switch for you what
um open your eyes and you thought to
yourself I I don't want this life I want
to do something different
I was sick of it I was just sick of it
dude I I hear me say man how old are you
I'm 22. I'm so proud of you
hey yeah thank you because I mean when
you're talking about food you're talking
about digital communication you're
talking about alcohol that also means
you had to come up with a new set of
friends and you had to wrestle dude
you're you're an absolute gangster I'm
I'm honored to get to talk to you it's
awesome it's awesome thank you yeah and
I love the nature of this question Blake
because you've got some ideas
that have come from your heart and
they're swirling in your head and I and
and I'm so glad you got John and I
together because you have gotten sick
and tired of being sick and tired and
now you're ready to make a a
contribution and can I just tell you
before we even get into this
that you're gonna get so much natural
soul level juice from contributing
something positive to this world
do you understand what I'm saying you'll
never have to medicate again if you
realize how valuable you are so let's
talk about these ideas anytime I talk to
somebody John who's got multiple ideas
I'd like to just have you list the top
two or three
and the order that they pop in your mind
because I think we're going to see a
pattern here so let's go
to them on paper great that's okay it's
perfect read them they all kind of
connect but I knew it I have local meal
prep company with supplement company
that I want to start I want to own a gym
eventually I want to influence others
online who want to live a healthier life
and are looking for it and I also want
to potentially do like a nutrition coach
for sports
okay great now let's look at the pattern
you said this yourself so I want you to
share with John and I what you see the
connection as being what's the thread
between those three ideas local meal
prep uh nutrition uh uh then own a gym
and then also influence people online
for exercising nutrition and then
nutrition for athletes what's the common
thread there uh well it's positive
influence on mental and physical health
yeah so coming at it from a food
standpoint food and exercise and the
positive mental health impact yeah
yeah well I mean John you you've
actually gone deep and gotten to be
really good friends with so those guys
these dudes and there isn't there is a
connection
um so what I'm seeing Here Blake is I'm
seeing a ladder that we need to develop
for you so I think you can do all three
of these things
you may do them separately you may do a
combination of the three but I think
it's a process for you as you come out
of some some some real tough stuff that
we create the right path for you so that
you keep walking forward and and adding
to the skill and the experience
necessary to one day get to that point
of having your own business does that
make sense
yeah yeah I think I'm stuck at like
where do I start yeah let me tell you
where you start on a lower run I don't
care
where the ladder is and let me explain
what I mean by this and John I want you
to actually speak into the mental side
of this with this advice my advice for
Blake is let's just get in the nutrition
space yes big giant space I don't care
if it's working at GNC go for five
months go get a job at GNC go get a job
at a local get a job at a gym I see how
that machine works I want him in the
space doing two things
getting experience
and getting Clarity that's now what I
mean by that Blake and I want to turn
this over to John for him to add
something right here in this moment and
we'll keep coming back to the long-term
path but when I say I want you getting
experience I want you just winning I
want you going in and being a part of
solving a problem that you care deeply
about which you've already given it to
us nutrition and exercise and its role
on our mental and physical health boom I
just I'm there getting experience being
a part of the solve that's huge for you
to get some wins and oh by the way
paychecks right then you're going to
start to develop uh not just out of the
experience you're going to get some
skill set but more importantly you're
getting Clarity on how the industry
Works where I want to be and it's in a
low pressure someone's paying me to
observe where I ultimately want to end
up John that's what I'm thinking and
Blake let me tell you this how long have
you been sober
uh it's 28 days all right excellent
excellent so I often get like let's say
there's a married couple and they one of
them cheats on the other one and they
decide to stay together and they go to
counseling a few times and then they
want to write a book and go on a
speaking tour
what I would tell them every step of the
way don't tell your personal story don't
go out and try to heal the world until
you've got both feet on solid firm
ground Ken's advice is right on because
you need to get into these industries
learn it while you're still healing
because you're not there yet you're
you're not even 30 days in brother you
got a ways to go before you turn the
corner this is going to give you
opportunity to practice practice
practice practice practice across the
board on yourself and on your job and
Blake we're gonna help you hang on the
line we're gonna give you my get clear
career assessment which is going to give
you even more of a focused Direction
long term to take our short-term advice
Blake proud of you number one number two
awesome go that direction that's where
you're supposed to be we believe in you
[Music]
foreign
look I love real estate and I want you
to have a house but I don't want a house
to have you that's why you need to get
in touch with Churchill Mortgage to make
sure you do this right these guys are
awesome they'll help you get on a
smarter mortgage plan because they're
committed to doing what's right for you
that means they check in every year with
free consultations to help you stay on
the right plan they show you how to save
money and interest so you can build
wealth faster they walk you through the
total cost of your loan so you can make
the best choice basically they care
that's why we call them Ramsey trusted
you can achieve debt-free home ownership
and Churchill is here to help go to
their site churchillmortgage.com Ramsey
to start your approval or get more
information
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
welcome back America you've joined the
conversation about your life
specifically your money your
relationships your work all three of
those are inextricably connected and you
need to be winning in all three and
we're here to help you do that Dr John
deloney joins me I'm Ken Coleman Ramsey
personality is here for you this hour
triple eight eight two five five two two
five is the number to jump in triple
eight eight two five five two two five
let's go to New York City New York the
Big Apple Tom is there Tom how can we
help
what's going on guys thanks for taking
my call today you bet
so um my wife and I are just about
finishing baby step three
um we finished paying off our all our
student bed and and cars um everything
except our mortgage just uh at the end
of last year great and um now that we're
coming up on the end of baby step three
having said about six months uh for an
emergency fund
um where I know the next steps you know
that are in the baby steps are saving 15
investing that in retirement and um and
paying off our home early but uh we're
at a point where next year we're looking
to
um kind of start a family and right now
we live in like a one bedroom uh
apartment and we're we're looking at you
know saving up to save up for a home so
I guess my question is um what's the
best way to kind of uh
save up for a home but also
um you know
still continuing on those baby steps
yeah well the next baby step is what we
call baby step 3B uh you don't have you
don't have the child yet correct did I
hear you properly that's right yeah so
am I hearing in your question a little
bit of uncertainty as it relates to how
much money should we be saving for the
baby before we start saving for the
house is that what I'm hearing
no it's mostly just for for that house
just to have because we would we would
need a little bit of more space or um
sure when we do start that all right so
let's just look at real numbers you guys
planning to stay in the area that you're
living in now
yeah pretty much we live just outside of
New York City okay so have you done any
research in the marketplace on a house
that's a good starter house for you guys
certainly big enough for you and mama
and baby
yeah yeah all right so what are we
talking about the market just to get a
few what's the price range that we're
looking at that's realistic it's not
like the nicest brand new neighborhood
because I can tell you John and I'll
tell you that doesn't matter we just
want a nice safe uh not a uh uh you know
a trap of just money going into an old
dilapidated house so based on that what
are we looking at as a purchase price
yeah so I think uh something that would
be doable for our range would be kind of
something along 500 000 which seems to
be on the the lower mid range but just
enough that uh we would need for for us
all right so John based on what we teach
we're looking at anywhere from 10 to 20
down payments so there's your number
yeah and
um a common trap dude that
um I fell into I I'm I'm confident
candid too
um
this baby when you bring this baby home
the baby weighs like six to ten pounds
and so we get this idea like I gotta
have another room and a special laundry
section and it's eight pounds it's like
a a heavy football
and so
um bo uh kids been open about this too
both Ken and I had very clear pictures
we probably you probably like me we went
my wife and I went to dinner it's like
we're gonna we're starting the Family
Planning process and it took my family
years to Ken's same thing years and so
what I don't want you to tell you that
to tell you this
I don't want you to get manic about
buying a house because you have to have
one before you have a kid and then
you're gonna go rush off and buy
something stupid that you can't afford
because you're gonna go with the with a
budget of five and then she's gonna see
something that she likes at 6 50 and
then you're gonna feel this like shame
that you can't provide and it's a whole
domino dude that almost every guy I know
goes through and then you end up with a
house and then it takes two years three
years four years and now you're in
another conversation about having
starting a family
I'll tell you to relax and get get 10 to
20 down and then you're in a position to
kind of buy what you want when you need
it right how long do you think it makes
sense how yeah how long will it take you
to get to that 10 to 20 Mark so we're
looking at uh uh a hundred thousand at
the at the most how long will it take
you to save that for 20 on a 500 000
house
yeah yeah that's that's a good question
um so if we so right now my wife and I
each put five percent into our into our
retirement right so
um if we were to keep that and just
continue saving as as if we have done
for our emergency fund
um I think by next September we'd able
we'd be able to have that 20 for a 500
years do it no brainer that's it and you
gotta listen to what John said John's
right we're gonna go ahead and save for
it but we're not gonna feel in a rush to
do it that's right and hey uh I I've
talked about this on the show too when
my son was one and a half maybe two we
sold our home and moved into a dorm a
residence hall it was a one and a half
bedroom I mean it's two bedroom
apartment
and my son was a maniac he was super fun
but I'm telling you you don't need to
sprint out and go create this vision for
this thing do it the right way I want
your kid to be born into a stress-free
house whether that is 650 square feet or
that 6 000 square feet and the best way
to assure you all have a stress-free
home is that y'all are communicating
together y'all on the same page and you
don't have money Wars man uh and you can
ask a piece that this baby comes home to
so good for you for thinking ahead man
but I'm with you 100 save that money get
that down payment and then get back to
investing as soon as you can John I
don't know if you have ever been back to
I'm assuming you have did you ever go
back to one or the childhood home you
grew up in yeah yeah do you remember
thinking this this is what I thought I
was like holy cow this is teeny tiny
dude but I remember as a kid thinking
man my house is huge so many rooms I
thought it was my favorite is going back
to like if you go back to your
Elementary School in the the lunchroom
it felt like a football stadium oh yeah
and then you go in there now and it's
like you got to take a knee to get a
drink yeah and it's it's about 35 square
feet total yeah it's this little bitty
and the reason I bring that up is I
think it it just really accentuates what
we're saying here and what you're
pointing out that you know what it's one
little kid that kid
won't even to the age of 8 9 10 still
won't have any kind of idea I stayed in
our first home until we were 12. yes and
I remember going back years later at 22
going how did we even get along in here
it looks like we would have sat on top
of each other yes and yet as I walked
through each room of that house
going back in my recollection I was like
I I used to think this room was the
coolest room ever yes this is not a room
I have a walk-in closet as big as this
now I again it was it was it was made
clear to me in a powerful way when my
son was three or four my wife got
opportunity to go teach at a school in
Brazil
um to go train some teachers as a part
of university project and they paid for
me and Hank to tag along so we went down
there and dude it was this magic I had
it all planned out father son two cans
were flying around like they were just
like Blue Jays we were picking mangoes
off the trees it was this whole thing
he has zero recollection yeah not none
yeah has no we wrote donkeys and nothing
he has no recollection of that now I'm
sure he built some synapses dads can be
trusted all the the time was good
he's got no memory of it and the number
of young parents who mortgage their
souls because they have this image of we
got to have their own bedroom and it's
got to be all decorated out it's got to
have all these giraffes painted on the
wall by by you know Banksy and all that
you don't need any of that stuff not at
all right you don't need that stuff do
it the right way over over and this is
from a guy who did it the wrong way man
who leveraged my family
into a massive hole that my kids got to
live the stress getting out of that hole
right I'll take you back to When Stacy
and I lived here in this area for the
first time and we bought our first house
and I remember it was 195 000 and I the
stress that it brought me three bedrooms
nice little house starter house okay
that has 11 million dollars yeah but we
barely made any money on it three years
later when we moved to Atlanta here's my
point I if I had to deal over it again I
would have probably just rented and
instead of putting the down payment on I
would have invested that that's right
saved it until we got to Atlanta rent
for a while we made some decisions that
I do all over again now going it was the
two of us absolutely we should have been
in a teeny tiny little Matchbox of a
house that's right so that's the idea
folks don't get this fever for
impressing other people or creating a
situation where your status feels really
good but it's not doing anything for
your lifestyle at all that's the rub be
careful of that I really appreciate the
call Tom and we're so excited for your
future you're doing this thing the right
way all right don't move he's Dr John
deloney I'm Ken Coleman and you're
listening to the Ramsey show more coming
up
[Music]
[Applause]
if you're like most people your home is
your most valuable asset and when you
want to make improvements it can feel
like everything costs too much or takes
too long but something as simple as
custom window coverings from blinds.com
can completely change your space and add
value to your home we've recommended
blinds.com for over a decade so you know
you can trust them from blinds drapes
and shutters to motorized Shades they
make it easy and affordable to upgrade
your entire home and their team is ready
to help with everything from design
consultation to measuring and
installation plus there are never any
misleading quotes or hidden fees ever
everything's backed by their 100 percent
satisfaction guarantee and shipping is
always free see why blinds.com is the
number one online retailer of custom
window coverings visit blinds.com to
save up to 45 off everything
site-wide go to blinds.com now to learn
more
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
folks glad to have you with us here on
the Ramsey Show I'm Ken Coleman joined
by John deloney here for you this hour
triple eight eight two five five two two
five triple eight eight two five five
two two five all right John uh you gotta
weigh in on this one today's question of
the day comes from Kyle in the uh this
always makes me laugh what do we say
this the official Ken Coleman community
on Facebook dude I don't have a
community is there an unofficial Ken
Coleman Community seven or eight of them
yeah uh so here is the question I'm
assumed to be retired principal and I'm
looking for ideas for work outside of
Education after 33 years in education I
would love to have some ideas of what
people have done for work after the
education career well that's a big big
onion to peel and if I were talking to
you in person Kyle I would ask
two questions
what did you enjoy most about being a
principal or educator because it
presumably you were a teacher and you
moved up so if you look at your 33
career 33-year career I want to know
as you look back the tasks or the role
that you played that you had great
enjoyment I want to write that down
because those are Clues to the Future
the second thing I would ask is the flip
side of that
what part of being an educator or
principal what part of that role those
tasks drained you so in other words what
lifted you and what drained you and I
want those two separate lists and here's
why I would ask you to do that in those
two answers are the clues to your future
I would also say John and I'm curious to
know your your take on this as an
educator former educator
I don't think that he needs to be
looking
necessarily in a diff through a
different lens different area yes but I
think once an educator always an
educator once an instructor always an
instructor different environment
different industry that's right yes but
I'm guessing that his answers to those
two questions are going to reveal the
type of work that he will do in the
future and I think he'll always be in
some ways an instructor a leader an
administrator just different context
that's where I'd start looking roles
that are similar but different lanes
because he's got great experience to
offer that's uh thoughts on that yeah
it's easy to feel like I've done 33
years in a box and yeah I'm useless
outside of this box and so when I read
this I was thinking okay I've hired a
ton of people in my career Kyle back
when I was working at University
especially I hired I came count how many
people I hired the number of people
who I would like to have the experience
of dealing with angry parents dealing
with nonsensical local politicians being
able to write you got to be able to
write to be able to deal with crisis and
intervention to be able to deal with you
as a principal let's say you're at an
elementary school teacher I mean
Elementary School principal you've got
30 to 75 direct reports all the teachers
report to you that's right um you've got
to deal with all kind of drama
I can't think of a person who's more fit
to walk into just about in the industry
you just want to walk into Kyle it's you
deciding what I what do I want to do and
you going into those conversations
knowing I'm not useless just because I'm
outside of the box I was in for 33 years
in fact it's the opposite I can bring a
whole new perspective on customer
service on dealing with crisis on taking
care of people who are hurting on
dealing with with institutional drama
which is about every company on planet
Earth right now you can do anything so
really it's going back to Ken's
questions what do you want to do I do
know Educators who did not want to talk
to a human right like I've done it for
33 years I loved math and I became a
math teacher I'm done talking to people
awesome it's clear Clarity like I know I
don't want this but you hit it on the on
the nail on the headcan most of us who
are in education
um end up in some sort of teaching role
a human relations role Human Resources
role where we're taking on hiring and
taking care of people because it's very
unuses who we are the operating word
here is people right so what people work
am I good at what people work do I enjoy
yes different way of asking the same
question I just listed but that's simple
then you go okay great and it's about
what you want to do because the the
messages you can do so many different
things John the experience and skill
that anybody gets over 33 years is
wildly valuable right so let's start
with that narrative that's the proper
mindset I've got something to offer yeah
where do I want to offer do I want to
offer it yeah especially in this job
market yeah we follow the heart let me
tell you this I This was
um in fact I may call your show one day
you can help me unpack this that would
be great I remember explicitly
um so my dad was a SWAT hostage
negotiator so when someone's going to
jump off a building or somebody had a
bomb my dad they called him and he
walked in and he was kind of the all
Shucks guy he would sit down and say
talk to people like hey what's going on
in your life tell me about your kids and
um
I remember calling him one night when I
was finishing a crisis call I just had
to tell a mom that her young kid had
passed away it was a hard night but I
remember leaving and asking and
reflecting myself on my drive home it's
2 30 in the morning the neighborhood's
asleep I'm driving home
and I called my dad the next morning and
I said what do I do when I realized
that the thing I'm best at in the world
is giving people really hard news with
Grace and being there with them in that
first moment that first Aftershock
moment
and I called him because that's what he
was great at and he said he gave me a
profile he said be really grateful you
found it right and now become really
good at that skill and make sure you've
got a an environment that allows you to
do your job well because that meant
you're gonna have to have some good
friends you're gonna have to have a
counselor you're gonna have to be on the
same page with your wife because that
what you're good at is really hard so
Kyle makes it down and go through like
here's what I'm really loved that I
really loved I really love dealing with
drama
ah I took my soul from me but I was
really good at it and it it fired me up
so that means I'm gonna have to create a
world where I'm gonna go in another
Corporation help them deal with their
institutional drama with their their HR
issues or people fighting with each
other and I'm gonna have to create a
world where I can do that in a healthy
way it's really good let me jump in
because I don't think you meant to say
it but it didn't the hard stuff didn't
take his soul away the hard stuff for
you you're still doing it every day
that's right right it gives me it gives
me it but it depletes you it depletes
but now here's the key yeah in the
moment it does not no it's a moment it
fires you up yes and John's heart if we
were to think of it like an engine with
pistons it's running a gun it's going
like this and it's great when you're
done yes and you leave a show
but here's the difference and your dad's
advice was right
you cannot give
what you do not have that's right so a
person who and I think there's some
people that listen to us today that feel
burned out
and what happens is John if you don't
replenish after being depleted so you've
given everything you've got when you
were in those crisis situations at 2 30
in the morning you're all alarms
everything you got you get in the car on
the way home and it's like a balloon
that's lost all of its air that's right
so how do we fill John back up and so
this is the thing and what but if we
don't figure that part out to go wait a
second I should feel
exhausted I blame the job and I walk
away from something that I love and I'm
great at right now what you got to blame
is your process for filling back that's
right so now we got to go to your dad's
point he was so on it your wife your
friends
exercise yeah nutrition all the things
we're learning our bodies are machines
yeah you got to take care of them and we
got to support the heart because if we
go heart heart heart all the time no
matter how many times I say follow your
heart don't miss the other part of the
advice I gotta follow my heart but I
cannot give what I do not have right and
so if I gotta change the tires and you
got to change it yeah because I gotta go
home and give to Stacy that's right and
the three kids I'm also a relational
being I'm not just this occupational
dude right right and so I think that's
the thing that is so important to
understand there's only so much your
heart can do if you don't replenish your
body and so and vice versa what would
you do would you go watch a funny movie
what I mean in all honesty like those
crisis situations in that law
enforcement what would you do to report
I was fortunate to have a supervisor
they would call me at three o'clock in
the morning and say walk me through what
you just saw how are you doing and that
was a so then get out of your body you
start talking about it yeah he Demands a
witness right so I just saw some stuff
I'm experiencing it occasionally I went
in and woke up my son and hugged him
after a hard one and he's a real
transfer of energy there that's I I
needed to put my hands on my son and say
he's still here right and then there was
moments the next morning when I went and
called the counselor and said I just
need a debrief and just gonna vomit and
I'm gonna leave and we'll high five so
it's everyone's got a different process
right I'll tell you what works for me
folks when I'm giving advice and
speaking all day I gotta go home and
read something I gotta learn something
if I'm learning something I now have
something I'm excited to maybe pour back
out that's cool whatever your thing is
John that's incredible advice hey don't
move more of your calls coming up
[Music]
oh
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsay show I'm Ken
Coleman joined by my colleague John
deloney we're here for you taking your
questions about your money for also
taking your questions where John and I
tend to focus all of our time in our
separate shows on the Ramsey Network and
that is relationships in your mental
health with with with the good doctor
here and then I don't have a degree so I
got no title I'm just a guy who's pretty
miserable for a while John and realized
I was longing for more meaning in my
work and I figured it out and now I tell
other people yeah but you know you have
I don't know how I got an official Ken
Coleman Facebook page his Facebook group
well I feel very I don't have one of
those yeah I feel very special but
that's not going to help me when I check
in at places and I go uh Dr Kim Coleman
we have a mutual friend who loves to
drop the title out you don't do that we
got a mutual friend I won't say his name
but he loves it when he checks in it's
like dude nobody cares so in my life
buddy my uh mom
was Dr deloney first my wife was Dr
Delaney second and so I'm just like this
knucklehead of the table you just needed
to keep up they're like oh feel fancy
fantastic they got the trash exactly I'm
impressed it's just too much school work
for me folks I have ADHD I don't do well
in school but uh hey anybody wants to
give me an honorary doctorate I'll sign
up for that I'll take it all uh hey we
got a lot of new listeners John we we
see the data it's very exciting and I
just want to say if you're new to this
show there's a lot of lingo a lot of
baby steps talk a lot of stuff John and
I'll say on a regular basis and some of
you are going man I I feel like I just
jumped in and it's about 55 60 miles an
hour so we have some genius people it's
probably James our fearless producer uh
if you go to ramseysolutions.com and
click on the get started button we're
going to help you figure out the next
best step for your journey to get where
you want to go so don't feel overwhelmed
go to
ramseysolutions.com and click on the get
started button and that's going to help
you you and by the way welcome the
water's warm here we're glad you're here
all right uh also and it's not because
somebody peed in it yeah well if anybody
would it would be you
that's that's fair uh hey uh you know
what else is uh is kind of confusing not
just jumping into a show that's been
around for three decades but also
dealing with your taxes that's why I
hire a specialist John because I would
be in jail not not because I was
dishonest but because I'm a disaster and
but it doesn't matter the RS doesn't
care they don't care about your disaster
excuse no they're going to lock you up
and we want you to get your taxes right
and uh some of you need to help and uh
some of you can do it with just a little
bit of guidance so we've got a couple of
tax tips for you all right if you picked
up a side hustle or started a business
this last year you've got a new tax to
pay it's called the self-employment tax
and that's tricky and the most important
thing to be able to navigate all the tax
nuances is to get organized gather
receipts any tax forms income as well as
all your expenses but we have a free tax
prep checklist that's going to take all
the fear out of this you can find it at
the Ramsey Solutions website and if this
sounds like too much for you welcome
that's me this all scares me my eyes are
going to roll around in my head it's not
good John and so I go to a Ramsay
trusted Pro one of our endorsed local
providers who can help you with
everything prepare your taxes and make
sure that you are making the most and
also not going to jail go to
ramseysolutions.com taxpro that's
ramsaysolutions.com
tax Pro that's one bill John
that I never mind paying nope I I don't
want to rat Stacey out she's not
listening so she'll never know but but
she's always like man it feels like
they're charging us more every year and
I go babe who cares whatever pay that
bill that's peace of mind that I don't
have to you know
bang pots and behind jail or whatever I
don't want to do that yeah exactly so
that's a that's a good I don't know what
that is either James is like what is
banging pots I was trying to come up
with an image from
what's that Tim Robbins we watch
different jail movies I think apparently
Shawshank Shawshank Redemption yeah
either way we need to move on yeah
before I get myself into more trouble
see just the very thought of doing my
taxes Fritz is my brain out I know and
you're watching it melt down right here
live on the air heads are falling off
yeah but Austin's waiting and he's
standing by with great patience Austin
in Madison Wisconsin Austin how can we
help
hey guys uh let's be on and talk to you
so I'm currently in a situation with
work where climbing the ladder is like
an impossible thing
um it's a my wife's family's uh business
and um
the reason it concerns me is it is uh
I started there about four years ago
after a two overseas and I make the same
amount I did four years ago
they're not great about negotiating pay
increases and then I also want to set an
example for my kids to go on and and
challenge themselves and do something
different than what I'm doing but hey
Austin let me let me jump in really
quick it's a two-part question number
one what is making it feel impossible is
it just the fact that every time you
bring this up it doesn't get addressed
or is a hard no and that's the first
question the second question is if all
of a sudden you sat down with them today
let's say we were able to give you some
master tip and you sat down with them
and they gave you the race would you be
calling us right now
um what's the first question what's the
first answer
yeah surprise you repeat that part what
is it what makes it feel impossible what
evidence do you have in your mind that
says this is impossible to get a
promotion
this business started 50 years ago and
um one of the guys that works there has
gotten four apparent increases in 50
years
um okay that's pretty confident so
there's been plenty of people in and out
the doors as times go on and persons go
off these last for a little bit more
it's always a hard no okay and so the
next question is if for some reason they
begin to give you regular raises and
promotions would you still be thinking
about leaving
no I I enjoy
I enjoyed for the most part okay that's
what I wanted to know now here's why I
asked that question
I think it's time to leave quit but I
want but I wanted to know did you enjoy
the work and the answer is you enjoy the
work so in these kind of situations John
it can create confusion for us because
we've got this we've got a little bit of
a wrestling match uh Austin and the
wrestling match is this I really enjoy
the work
but I don't feel I'm being recognized
and rewarded and so it's a cocktail of
confusion enjoy the work but then you
don't feel good about yourself because
the environment you're in so I all that
to say you know what kind of work you
enjoy we're looking for that in Madison
Wisconsin and Austin
um you're in kind of a strange
cocktail here where you've been tasked
by your wife's family to take care of
her right like be a good steward
you know and
also we're gonna pay you less than your
worth or less than you're out in the
market so it's this conflicting
world and what I want to tell you is be
a good Steward of your family and be a
good Steward of your work ethic and the
things that bring you Joy and treat hair
family with dignity and respect as you
leave and it's time to go
and don't look back for one single
second at all it's a great season it's
fun cool bye
absolutely and Austin would you rather
make yourself and your wife and your
family happy or
the family members who are your leaders
happy which one would you rather make
happy
as to how hard her father works and how
hard it is to replace somebody in these
positions I get it but have you talked
to your wife actually I want to bring
John in on this I want to bring John on
this what's the conversation been
between you and your wife on this
decision
um it's so it's it's hard for her to
even talk like if I come home from a day
and it's like it's so hard to be
efficient I love efficiency it's hard to
be efficient because the Shop's filled
with stuff and at the moment I I say
that you know there's like a pack rat in
there that doesn't allow you to have
space to work
her head kind of goes down to the side
but that's because that's because she
internalizes that business her that
business is her mom and dad right so
when you talk about the business you're
clowning on her mom and dad which I
don't care how long you're married
that's never cool and so no
I I I
she's she is asking you to fix a problem
that you can't solve Bingo and that's
not your job your job is to honor her
take care of your family and provide for
your family with with whatever
Arrangement y'all have set up
um and so I think it's a clear
conversation with her hey I'm going to
begin looking for work elsewhere or
start having quiet conversations
elsewhere and when you land something
then sit down and say Here's the
transition I'm going to make
um and I hope you'll I hope you'll join
me in this yeah
Austin you got to do it you know you got
to do it so let's win your wife's heart
on this JD always good to be with you
sir and I think James and the crew
behind the glass are keeping us on the
air I want to thank you America for
listening this is your show this is the
Ramsey Show
foreign
hey it's Ken if you love the show and
want a deeper dive on your money Journey
we have a Weekly Newsletter that gives
you trending and helpful articles and
tips on following the Ramsay way go to
ramseysolutions.com today to sign up for
our newsletter again that's
ramsesolutions.com to sign up for our
Weekly Newsletter
[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studio this is the
Ramsey show this is where we talk about
your life with you specifically your
money your relationships and your work
three
inextricably fancy word there it just
means they are absolutely connected
there's nothing you can do about it we
want you to win in all three areas
because you're not it's affecting the
other areas once you'll win in all three
areas and that's why we do it I'm Ken
Coleman joined by Dr John deloney triple
eight eight two five five two two five
is the number to jump in we'll take your
calls on any of those subjects triple
eight eight two five five two two five
all right John to that end uh when you
and I are together for the Building
Wealth live events we do a fun pre-show
where we talk about
work and love relationships and work you
know and how they uh are and absolutely
connected and I shared something on my
show earlier today the Ken Coleman show
that I honestly would have loved have
had you in studio
um and it was based on a comment that a
guy made on social media to me recently
we were talking about people making
money and that money's not enough you
know you can make a lot of money but at
the end of the day that kind of wears
off and if you're miserable or you're
not experiencing real meaning
as you derive it as in this matters to
me
um it can get pretty old fast and a guy
goes oh that's crazy and he's like I do
you know I'd shovel this you know so my
question to you is
what would you I mean what work what
miserable work would you do
for a million dollars is there is there
work uh my my stock answer is uh
there's very very few jobs on planet
Earth I would not do that you would not
do for a million dollars right and you
know my response to that is but no you
wouldn't it's exactly right I would do
it for about three weeks and then yeah
and that's because you're really tough
and I wouldn't be able to take it yeah
three weeks a long time that's right all
right I have found over the course of my
career
that when I find myself in moments
without purpose or without meaning or I
don't feel like I'm contributing I feel
like I'm a glorified administrative
assistant or that I'm in a in a
structure where success is not possible
the dollar amount matters zero because
what what happens to you from your
personal experience you and I have both
been there I it's this awesome Cascade
of Rage to anger to this to reality to
Pure boredom yeah I just you start
straight off in a space like what am I
doing here yeah so this isn't just John
and I's experience and opinion John what
does science say can we can we is it
okay yeah is it okay to look at some
science so scientists have found that
monotonous work in other words using the
work that the word that John just used
boredom boring work kinetic negatively
impact Mental Health
be a huge cause of stress and ultimately
lead to burnout
well let's go further the chronically
bored are at a higher risk for drug
addiction alcoholism and compulsive
gambling in her paper Neuroscience
reveals that boredom hurts Dr Judy
Willis a neurologist and former
classroom teacher claims that when we're
bored our judgment
goal directed planning risk assessment
focus and control over our emotions all
suffer yikes John yeah and here's the
the crowd from boredom the crappy way
we've set up uh in like uh corporate
structures business structures let me
see corporate business structures is
only a couple of people at the tip Tip
Top get the because they're so
sophisticated and they're so such good
planners and thinkers the rest of y'all
just y'all mind your business and we'll
Pat you on the head and we'll tell you
what to do later with your TPS reports
instead of I think you and I were
talking earlier Jocko so eloquently says
you better equip the front line people
to own this thing make decisions and go
and instead of minimizing the the or
collapsing the decision-making structure
and the purpose making structure into a
few Elites that it's it's your industry
will end your company will say that's
why you do it so the the bumper sticker
is for those of you that are feeling
this or those of you that are leading
people be careful of monotony because
monotony robs people of autonomy and
let's just
simple words freedom freedom freedom to
make a choice it's a Cornerstone of
mental health physical health all of it
relational health so there you go by the
way one last piece of data corn fairy of
well-known uh management firm pulled
nearly 5 000 professionals and the top
reason that people look for a new job is
boredom boredom we as humans
long for progress and in order to get
progress we must be challenged that's
what is at the core of enjoyment at work
am I being challenged the moment that
I'm bored
I get distracted and I go distract
myself with pleasure
but what I need is progress that's why I
I think the whole corporate speak the
whole leadership speak we have it
backwards I don't think you climbed the
ladder I think the moral responsibility
you obtain or and are given and the more
people you have to serve in a leadership
capacity you're moving down the ladder
carrying more and more weight and
passing along those opportunities for
people to
do hard things to fail to have purpose
to go out and Achieve and go go go go go
go go go go
it's not reserved for a few highfalutin
thinkers
the the more responsibility you get you
are moving down the ladder carrying more
and more of that responsibility wait
that's what you're getting paid for
that's right right it's to balance it
all not to stand up there and dust your
Journal off and to be like oh don't
trouble me with my thoughts that's your
people are look around man they're gonna
leave they're gonna leave absolutely
gonna leave because they want a better
life you think you're trying to give
them a better job they want a better
life and Until you realize the
connection between the work it's not
just a better Financial life it's a
better mental health it's better
everything everything because we want to
be challenged so uh really interesting
stuff there for those of you who feel
stuck in one of those uh type jobs John
and I'd love to help you jump in but
let's get to James in Indianapolis
Indiana right now James how can we help
hey guys uh my name is
um sorry uh I have my question today is
I'm 19 years old and I'm thinking about
getting married and with that comes the
engagement the wedding and then after
that buying a house
and I'm wondering if I should be
investing over I don't know like a six
year time frame or if I should just be
saving up cash that whole time
when's the wedding
uh I haven't even engaged I'm thinking
about it in like the next year or two
are you do you have any debt
no okay so you you're familiar with our
baby steps right yes so what baby step
are you in are you in baby step four
essentially
four yeah okay great uh I wouldn't or
three be I guess technically so you're
technically saving for a house right now
I mean sort of it's kind of a five-year
Vision how much are you gonna how much
dude you've got horses and carts all
over the place man listen brother like
go get a job and work really hard and if
you're already at baby step if you if
you want to start saving for a house for
yourself great if you think I'm gonna be
married in the next 24 to 36 months save
your money because you're going to want
to make that a joint purchase with your
wife and then dude work really hard and
put money like put your 15 in your
mutual fund through your 401 at work or
um call smartvestor Pro go to
ramseysolutions.com and click on
smartvestor pros and go down that route
um or put it in a money market account
and save your money dude like don't you
you were way way way way overthinking
this enjoy being young enjoy being
engaged and enjoy being married man the
rest of that stuff will work itself out
just follow the baby steps don't get too
sophisticated yeah so don't stop the
baby steps One Foot In Front of the
other let's make sure she says yes
that's what I'd be locking in on let's
close the deal John gotta make sure
she's gonna say yes so we can move
forward with everything else but thank
you for the call hey he's Dr John
deloney I'm Kidd Coleman this is the
Ramsey Show
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
we've been doing business at Ramsey for
more than 30 years by now we're a
well-oiled machine but it wasn't always
that way yes we've always had a vision
always had determination and a drive to
help people but what we didn't have was
one central place to access all our
numbers so that we could get further
ahead or quickly see when we needed to
Pivot we were always jumping back and
forth between different systems and
spreadsheets so when netsuite by Oracle
helped us Wrangle our Revenue inventory
expenses and more into one place here's
a game changer and netsuite's number one
Cloud Financial system can help your
business gain the same visibility
because businesses thrive on timely data
and netsuite's real-time analytics can
help your business have immediate access
to your numbers daily so you always know
where you stand and you can move quickly
so go to netsuite.com Ramsey today and
set up a free product tour that's
netsuite.com Ramsay
[Music]
welcome back America you have joined the
conversation here on the Ramsey Show
helping you with your money your
relationships and your work I'm Ken
Coleman Dr John deloney joining me in
studio this hour a lot of you are
planning to move sometime soon and uh
well that's exciting got to be real in
most places around the country you're
going to be facing sky-high home prices
and interest rates
aren't returning to their record low so
that doesn't make home ownership
impossible but if you want to buy or
sell you've got to make sure you're
financially ready
and that you've got a trusted and
experienced real estate agent to walk
you through it not a family friend like
Uncle Larry who just got his license
last month
someone who knows what they're doing
they've been doing it for a long time
and they're going to take good care of
it you can find that High Caliber Ramsay
trusted agent through our endorsed local
providers program we vet these Agents
from around the country so that you have
the best support whether you're moving
from Florida to Alaska or buying your
first home somewhere in between you know
I kind of expected you to come in with a
little Lee Greenwood from the lakes of
Minnesota to the hills of Tennessee I
thought that would have been good there
go to ramseysolutions.com agent
ramseysolutions.com agent to find a
Ramsay trusted real estate agent today
that's important now that song's gonna
be in my head I know I've done it I've
gone and I've ruined it and messed your
track yeah yeah there you go see you
almost did it hey let's get uh to the
phones now is the time to stop singing
John
um Antonia is joining us in Detroit
Michigan Antonia how can we help
Hi how are you we're having a blast
what's going on
so my question today is I don't trust my
boyfriend with money we do we have a
future
I want to back that question up
um let's stop it you added a second part
to it that is not super necessary you
don't trust your boyfriend period
yes
what else do you not trust a mom besides
money
um he I I found like him on these like
social media like talking to
other women he felt like it's not
cheating but Felicia wow what's what's
his explanation for that
I'm sorry can you repeat that what's his
explanation because you said uh he
doesn't think it's cheating so I'm
curious what does he call that
yeah I told him I'm like that's cheating
oh it's not cheating because it's not in
a physical form I'm like you're like
lusting over your women you're seeing
online no boy bro dude
those gas lights Are Burning Brightly
aren't they listen
um let me ask you this so he's not here
to defend himself
no so let me ask you the only person I
got to talk to is that cool
why do you think so little of my friend
Antonia that you're settling for this
well it's not that yes it is I think yes
it is why
well maybe you have a point so
um I'm a single mother
um with a three-year-old son I'm new
like new to like motherhood me and the
father it didn't work out
um I injured my back at work so
and I'm like I needed this surgery so I
ended up gaining all of this weight you
know like when you have a partner you
expect your partner to be there for you
and I feel like I didn't get that
because like when I was off work for a
year
um when we have fights or anything the
first thing he brings up is oh I paid
your rent well I'm like well like you
might as well say you're a roommate
because you live here we're not married
you know
so it's it's a little bit of everything
so
so is he he's a bit of Security even
though he's not treating you well it's
like well at least he's doing that he
was right well but here's the thing that
so it's really common that all these
other stories that we were told
eventually become the stories we we tell
ourselves
and you've got a narrative that you're
worth less because you gained weight
you've got a narrative that
because you got hurt and you reached out
to the person who was supposed to be
your partner in this in this adventure
called life called raising a kid and he
weaponized that against you and said
well look at what I'm doing for you
um you have this story that you're a
single mom and that you're now somehow
less than all those stories are false
100 yeah they're not true
I agree and so I do one thousand percent
believe that whoever you're dating is
probably a lot of fun is probably makes
you laugh and probably makes you feel
loved and all three of those things are
amazing
and he's making other women feel that
way too
and when you say I have a need
I'm uncomfortable with he makes you feel
crazy and stupid for having that thought
or need or feeling not supporting you
yes and so you don't trust him on a
number of different issues money is one
of them I was a train wreck when it came
to money
but I was a trustworthy guy does that
make sense I would never tell somebody
like man that my husband spins like
crazy we figure that out
if I had said
um and I was baiting you a little bit
when I said what else do you not trust
him on if you had said nothing he's
actually super iron Cloud he's
trustworthy then that would have been a
different answer
um but you
ah you're not gonna like this at the end
of the day you don't trust you
yeah and I want you I agree to reinvest
in you that's exactly right let's stay
there for a second Anthony you called
and asked us do we have a future you
know the answer but you know John's
right you don't trust your answer so you
called these two yahoos to see what our
take was but your answer is what do you
have a future with this dude yes or no
no but see it's the I don't think so
John's on something you don't trust your
own judgment
to kick this guy to the curb and you're
worthy of being trusted dude you're an
awesome mom you're a great employee
you're a good friend you're worthy of
being trusted
thank you is that fair and I'm not just
pulling smoke at you I've hey trust me
you've listened to this show if you if
you were out to lunch we would tell you
John here's I'm asking a question on
behalf of my friend okay
just because we make a bad decision
and and we kind of take good judgment
out of the equation for someone in a
relationship doesn't mean that we have
bad judgment the rest of our life true
or false false yeah and in fact um but
is that what's going on here she knows
it wasn't a good decision maybe she's
made some poor relationship decision all
of a sudden she goes I just don't make
good decisions but that's not true well
I think it's easy to and tell me if I'm
wrong Antonia it's easy to feel like
you're a single mom someone's told you
you've got these defects I'm the only
one that's ever gonna love you I'm the
only one that's paying your rent with my
money it's easy to make that those that
voice into your own voice and you start
telling yourself like for manipulation
that's right and then somebody walks
along and they're willing to give you
half of themselves
all right I'll tell you I love you I'll
tell you you're pretty I'll help pay the
bills and you start to think that's all
yeah and then yeah and want credit for
it you're getting me for a discount
exactly and you are you start thinking
well this is all that I'm ever gonna get
this is all this is going to be 100
and when this is especially real in
couples that experience infidelity
people often think that that like
finding out that the person you're
married to or you love cheated on you is
is the most devastating part that is
devastating
but the most devastating long-term thing
I think is you lose trust in yourself I
can't believe I missed that I can't
believe that I'm worth this little I
didn't even know how what how what a
loser I would like you lose trust in
yourself and it's hard to do anything
it's hard to get a job it's hard to
stand up with your to your kids it's
hard to do anything in your community
because you feel so you feel so small
and so I want you to hear Ken and I tell
you stand up man yeah you're worth too
much you got too much value and
someone's gonna recognize you for who
you are
um and I also don't want to blow smoke
at you you probably need to go talk to
somebody you probably need to get a
group of women in your life where you
can practice standing up on your own two
feet right now the greatest gift you can
give somebody in the future
um is you working really really hard on
you in this season
is that yeah and that's like that's
another thing too like I know it's like
he weaponized because I because I you
know like I'm a victim of molestation
and things like that so he he uses that
and you know that I suffered from
anxiety done hey hey anybody who
weaponizes that sort of pain done done
he's manipulating you I you know what
James would never allow it but if we had
time I'd call the guy up for you right
now break up with him for you I I would
dump him uh for you it's not the kind of
show we do John is probably not healthy
but that's what I would like to do this
dude is a loser and we know what we do
with losers we fire him we get rid of
them you're out you're done no longer
does he get to play in your world you
are worth so much more Anthony and thank
you we believe in you this is the Ramsey
Show
[Music]
y'all there's a lot you can't control
when it comes to health care but there
is something you should check out that
can help Christian Healthcare Ministries
chm is not Insurance it is budget
friendly biblically based Health cost
sharing that means a community of
members helping share the burden of each
other's health care costs they help
people just like you in all 50 states so
see if chm could be right for your
family learn more today at
chministries.org budget
[Music]
thank you
welcome back America you've joined the
conversation here on the Ramsey Show I'm
Ken Coleman joined by Dr John deloney
and in the lobby of the Ramsey World
Headquarters on the debt free stage is
Wesley and Brett welcome thank you you
guys you guys ready to do a debt free
scream I I assume yes we are oh that's
so fun okay let's get the details let's
get the story uh how much debt did you
pay off we paid off sixty one thousand
six hundred and eleven dollars not that
we're counting every dollar I'm gonna
round it up to 62 000 for my feeble
brain and how long did it take 14 months
14. oh y'all were cooking wow yeah and
uh what was your range of income during
this time uh it started at uh 142 000
and ended at 160. oh tell me about that
what do we do to get it up to 160. uh
just normal
um pay increases and just working some
overtime okay great what do you guys do
for a living
um I am a registered nurse oh good uh
I'm an aerospace technician oh in other
words I'm a genius I can't even spell
those two words together that's
impressive all right great so okay 14
months ago take us back what was the uh
Genesis for this journey where you guys
really got after it yeah it started a
little further back than that for me it
started back in like August of 2015. I
realized that I was incredibly broke
like eight dollars broke and about 500
of that wasn't mine
and so I
needed to do something
and I turned to Mom and she was like hey
remember that Dave Ramsey guy I told you
about and I was like no
she's like well maybe you should listen
to it so I listened to The Total Money
Makeover and
realized that I needed to change and do
something different and then we met
about four and a half years ago
and
that was kind of my start
um I started on my own as well I
um just found
um The Total Money Makeover in the
library I just decided to pick it up
um
uh read through the book started trying
to implement it and I was in a in my
former marriage I found out that you
need a partner that is going that's
going to be willing to do the sure go
through the process with you so
really I used some of the the
the um the things I use the budget just
basic budget but then couldn't really go
through you were all in is what you're
saying and then you guys meet and so I'm
just curious you guys both knew about
Dave and and on some level we're going
after it uh at what point in the dating
relationship do we realize hey we both
are aware of this concept and and then
how did that bring you guys together uh
the first date oh wow yeah
who brought it up first that'd be me uh
that would be me I basically said you're
either like you have to do this with me
we're like doing this I love this did
you also happen to mention hey and I
know you're an aerospace engineer but
quit hanging out in libraries did you
mention that too he likes the library
good for you man good for you I do too
okay yeah and we got married and um
we've been married just over a year and
a half and
tackled it right when we combined it
this was your newlywed project this is a
newlywed project this was date one of
dating life and then we go we do me a
huge favor I
I had like how did the conversation go
that way because I can just imagine like
you're beautiful and he's like he's like
man I can't believe I got a date with
with her and you like order the
appetizer hopefully it was the most
expensive one and then you lean over and
you say
um if you want this this comes with Dave
Ramsey and like how did that happen I
think I was like how do you feel about
debt and he's like well I have some but
I don't really like it and I was like
okay I was like do you want to get out
of it and he was like yeah I'm like okay
we can we can continue
wow okay we just yeah it was basically
like are you in or not and it worked
from there wow so let me ask you what
was the debt comprised of
it was
um some family loans student loans
credit card
I think that was the end of yours how
much did you each clean up uh before you
got married
um I cleaned up about 50 in about five
years before we got married okay and the
the 62 000-ish was mostly mine oh okay
so you still said yes oh wow wow hey
well played Wesley lead with that next
time yeah so but we also cash flow at a
wedding right before that we cash flowed
that and we also cash flowed some
medical bills about twelve thousand
dollars worth of Medical in the middle
of all of this wow so it was a it was
quite the journey it was we had to dig
deep so what does it take people are
listening in right now uh what would you
all say to those folks that are
wondering can it be done and if so and I
know you've believed the answer is yes
so what's the key I I think one having a
partner is huge having somebody to do it
with you makes a huge difference
um that really was kind of the ticket to
get it done so quickly I was like end
the budget for sure the budget is
life-changing who are your big
cheerleaders parents for sure those
people over there Marions his parents
who aren't here with us today like in
the studio but parents for sure were
huge we had a lot of questions about
like why why don't you have a credit
card it's fine
yeah a lot of people had questions and
and what was the key to kind of drowning
those voices out
trusting it I guess trusting the plan
trusting the process
yeah what is it like being an aerospace
engineer rolling up to work in a used
Corolla like because your co-workers
kind of have a sense of what you make
and they know you're married to a
medical professional and they look at
you like what are you doing dude uh you
know I have uh yeah you see a lot of
really nice cars out in the parking lot
and
not a Corolla it's a it's a an escape so
it's not not the flashiest vehicle but
yeah I just just knowing that later on
if we want to get those flashier
Vehicles we can go ahead and do that
I'll be honest with you I like the
Corolla more than the Escape I wouldn't
be I wouldn't be acting like that
escapes better than a Corolla over there
man like I don't know man no we're just
giving you a hard time that's really fun
so uh now what is it like on the other
side of this you guys haven't been
married that long and you've got this
debt behind you this is a big victory
you're standing on the stage today it
took a lot to get here what does it feel
like
it feels really good it's it's weird
seeing money in our account like there's
like going out of the door as soon as it
comes in there's like a there's a comma
in the account oh I like that we didn't
see commas for a long time so
how has it changed your vision as a
couple because when you start this
journey we're now like laser focused
we're in a tunnel gazelle intense now
here you are on the debt free stage
about ready to do your scream how has it
changed your vision as a couple what are
you guys dreaming about talking about
I feel like we can we just know that we
can do kind of whatever we I'm the
spreadsheet nerd so I have spreadsheets
that show us our potential trajectory
and where we're going and what our lives
might look like
in the future and we can just we can do
what we want I love it well and you guys
when you start talking about trajectory
you have a aerospace engineer for a
husband I mean now he knows everything
about trajectory that would intimidate
me I love that you use that word okay
who do you got with you today to join
you on the stage for the screen this is
Brooke Brooke and tell us about Brooke
Brooke is 12. uh-huh and yeah did she
walk through this journey enough to
where she knows what happened how big of
a deal this is very much so we've been
talking about money and trying to teach
her better than we maybe try to get her
listen better than we did Brooke listen
listen to him I love it good stuff well
hey we've got a couple things we want to
give you right here uh on the desk we're
gonna give you a copy of Dave's Total
Money Makeover for you to give to
someone else and you get to be a part of
that Legacy and then you're on your way
to being baby steps millionaires that's
Dave's latest book so we're going to
give those two uh you as well as just a
Memento to say hey we're so proud of you
so let's do this you guys ready for your
screen
and Brook's ready too I mean like really
give it some volume here Brooke are we
ready okay here we go we got Wesley
Brett and Brooke from the Denver
Colorado area here to do their debt-free
screen they paid off a hundred excuse me
sixty two thousand dollars I rounded up
in 14 months making 142
000 all the way up to 160
000 Wesley Brett Brooke it's time let's
hear your debt free scream all right
ready three three two one
[Music]
[Applause]
family stare into a completely different
Future No weight of debt dreams Galore
spreadsheets that support the dreams
that's why we do what we do big thanks
to them for sharing their story with us
all right jolt move we got to pay some
bills where we're coming right back this
is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
thank you
welcome to the Ramsey Show I'm Ken
Coleman Dr John deloney is my colleague
and he joins me in studio this hour the
phone number for you to jump in is
triple eight eight two five five two two
five eight eight two five five two two
five let's go to Jackson Mississippi
where Chris is on the line Chris how can
we help
hey uh how are you guys doing we're
having a blast how can we help
uh thank you for taking my call long
time a long time listener I've been I
went to spu in 2005 and uh I've been
baby step four so uh the process works
and thank you so much way to go man
uh the reason I called is because uh I
uh I was in the United States Air Force
I retired after 22 years
and uh I've been in a job
um that was comparable to what I used to
do when I was younger younger troop
younger Airman and uh and I kind of feel
like um I mean I've been in the same
place for about five years and I feel
like man what's what's next and I'm kind
of kind of lost I've listened to both of
your books and um and man I've listened
to Total Money Makeover like 50 times in
the car just trying to grind through to
get the baby step forward but uh I'm
still like at a loss about
what's next what's the time frame by
which you need or want to make a
decision
I have no time frame I can make a
decision now or when I'm 65. okay I'm 45
years old right now okay so you can walk
from the military at any time you're not
locked in for a certain amount of time
uh I retired from the military after 22
years oh I missed that I apologize okay
so sorry are you doing anything right
now what are you doing for an occupation
I am a test technician yes okay and how
much is that related to the type of work
you did in the military
um it's fairly similar uh however
um uh if you think of it like this uh
you know when you when you stay in for
22 years you typically retire around to
be about 87 so a senior enlisted leader
yeah uh this job that I took is kind of
bringing me back to being more like an
E4 or like a senior Airman okay and uh
it was a nice little break at first
um uh but uh I've kind of I kind of
missed the leadership part of it I miss
it I missed that so that's what we've
got to pay attention to is when someone
presents themselves as I don't know
what's next let me tell you what I've
experienced Chris and you can tell me if
I'm wrong in your case
what that usually means is I've got an
idea or two or maybe more
but I don't know how to make that
transition I don't know how to get there
I I'm interested in these mountains I'm
not quite sure how to climb them is that
what's really going on with you
I think so what is it all right then why
don't you just tell me not worry about
how it sounds
what is it that you want to do more
specific than what you just share which
is I want to be leading people you love
leading a team of people so specifically
what are you wondering about that you're
not quite sure how to get to
I think I have this roadblock in my head
about not having uh not having a
bachelor's degree I think that that's my
biggest block that I have all right
let's let's play this out all right okay
let's just assume you don't need a
bachelor's degree because I'm here to
tell you you don't what would you be
doing tomorrow if you just snapped your
fingers who would you be leading where
would you be leading
I don't know people that wanted to be
there that's for sure right
um you get my point here you're not it's
not industry specific
no it's really experience specific
you have an incredible resume where
you've led men and women true or false
true you're really good at leading men
and women true or false
medium nah that's a bunch of garbage if
I interviewed everybody that was ever
under you would they say that you're a
solid good leader
uh you'd get a mixed bag all right okay
did you learn something did you learn
something from those times where you
know and I appreciate your humility and
honesty have you learned from those
leadership mistakes
I have okay so you can come in and lead
a team of people right now
true or false I could all right so
that's the mindset so really we start
looking at okay is there an industry
that I'm more interested in than others
but I'm looking for management
leadership positions in Jackson
Mississippi just to start do you
understand what I'm saying yes like
let's just say all right let's just see
what's out there but this idea that I've
got to have a degree is is based on a
cultural Trend that's been going on now
for 60 70 years where well it's kind of
the way of weeding out the losers but
those times have changed we're in a job
economy right now where there are
organizations near you that are looking
for somebody that have has the
experience and the skill of leading
people they can train you to the nuances
of the role do you believe that
I do that's really kind of easy and
Chris if you walk into a business in
Jackson Mississippi and
they look at you and say man I
appreciate 22 years of service
but you gotta have that bachelor's you
don't want to work there man that's
right you don't want to work there and
if you were going to tell us hey I want
to go be I want to go to be a nurse and
I want to go be a nurse practitioner I
want to go to med school or something
then we would tell you to go to college
man but what you're telling us is you
want to lead and you want to get back
into some management potential and lead
a group of people to success and you
don't even care what the mission is
that's how that's how focused you are at
being a leader at some point Chris you
got to stop being Chris's Own Worst
Enemy man
I think you are the person who believes
in you the least among the among the
three of us right now
so if you don't know me John
no and hey let me let me tell you this
the number of people and I bet kids got
similar of my former students my friends
who were in the military who got out and
immediately jumped into quote unquote
their dream job or into med school or
into law school you did A very wise
thing you got out of the military and
you just went and got a job you got your
feet settled back you learned how this
wacky culture like you got you got to
re-enter Humanity in a different way and
now you're ready for what comes next so
you didn't waste five years man you did
a really wise smart thing okay quit
beating Chris up and go get something
good
thank you sir I got to thank Dave for
that because Total Money Makeover on the
drive to work every single day has
helped out quite a bit listen those are
cool but me and Dave and Ken like we
just run our mouth on the radio dude and
we are great we type you're the one
who's been put in the work driving back
and forth from back and forth and back
and forth you're the hero on this deal
okay Chris I want to leave you with one
thing I'm going to give you my get clear
career assessment that I think is a
wonderful tool for you to take 20
minutes or less is going to give you
some real defined ideas around the work
you love and the results that matter to
you but I'm just curious when you're
leading
what is the result that most fires you
up when you at the end of the day you go
you know what this result was obvious
and that's what gives me great joy how
would you articulate that
uh I I think the best way I can explain
it is when I've had well when I've had
some some difficult troops that I really
try to get through to and I try to pour
my heart and soul into them and ten
years later they say hey
um I really appreciate what you try to
do for me and I wish I would have
listened to you more
that that means a lot to me all right
now there that's exactly what your what
does exactly what you're asking no it's
exactly what I was asking for because
what you just revealed are the people
you most enjoy leading there's your clue
where are the people and when you called
them difficult troops off the air when
you're not under pressure one homework
assignment I want you to write down what
you now know is you look back on your
time with those difficult troops as you
put it what were their pain points what
was in their past what were some threads
that you can now look back and go they
all kind of shared this or these were
commonalities where are those people
in Jackson Mississippi who's serving
them that is where we want to get you to
and dude I'm telling you right now this
is probably not in in your scope but
right when you said that I thought you
would make an incredible High School
teacher or incredible coach an
incredible guidance counselor yeah an
incredible somebody that will is not
afraid to get in the messiness of other
people's lives and walk with them from
this messy moment to the light at the
end of the tunnel man and that
opportunity is everything everywhere
where what are some non-profit or even
government mentoring programs look you
listen there are some young men out
there who need to come into contact with
you am I right
I would hope so you know so stop saying
that what is going on Chris you've got a
track record to break it through with
what you called
problem or uh Soldiers with difficulties
they look back and say what you said
made sense Chris you got so much to
offer go find those people who need that
Mentor that coach that guide Chris you
got so much to offer thank you for
calling thank you sir for your service
you're a great American John deloney
great hour always fun to be with you
James the crew thank you guys so very
much to you America this is your show
this is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
hey it's Dr John deloney if you love the
show and want a deeper dive on your
money Journey we have a Weekly
Newsletter that gives you trending and
helpful articles and tips on following
the Ramsay way just go to
ramseysolutions.com today to sign up for
our newsletter again that's
ramsesolutions.com to sign up for our
Weekly Newsletter
[Music]
foreign
from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studio this is the
Ramsey show where we talk about your
life with you specifically your money
your work your relationships phone
numbers triple eight eight two five five
two two five I'm joined by Dr John
baloney I'm Ken Coleman and we are here
for you this hour triple eight eight two
five five two two five let's go to
Charlotte North Carolina Celeste is
waiting there Celeste how can we help
hi thank you so much for taking my call
you bet
um my main question is is my boyfriend
and I should split rent 50 50 or buy
percentage of income in the future
say what
are y'all are y'all moving in together
um so we've been discussing living
together in the future I'm 22. he's 23.
um he just graduated from college last
year and he's making 79 right now I'll
be done this year with I'm making 65k
and I said I would prefer to be engaged
before moving in together and we're both
lucky enough that our parents are fine
with us staying home saving up money
doing the baby steps but Eve wants to
get a town home in a year and a half
from now and wants me to move in with
him and says he intends to marry me and
that he proposed before two years if we
get along living together
I would say if you were my sister or my
daughter or my good friend I would say
he is out of his mind I would agree okay
um and in this I'm going to give this to
you like I'm a Christian guy I teach
Sunday school sometimes okay so I'm
gonna put that out there that's not like
I'm bringing this this is the data
couples that move in together are more
likely to get divorced
because here's why you play house you
practice you feel like you're practicing
marriage
but you're do it without the
the in like like hammered into concrete
come what may we're still going to be
here together
and so you it's it's like it's like
jumping out of an airplane and your
parachute isn't fully tied up yet
and so right I can tell you if it wasn't
for marriage there's multiple times over
the course of my 20 years with my wife
we would not still be dating we would
have broken wow but we're married and we
both committed to each other we're in
this come hell or high water this is
happening and so we stuck it out and we
had to figure out how to do something
differently okay so that's what here let
me give you the other thing that's
making me more uncomfortable than that
um I also have to be honest there's been
plenty of people who move in together
get married and their lives are fine
okay so I'm also gonna I know that
exists
I don't like the fact that you put a
value down and your boyfriend blew you
off and said actually we're gonna do
this
and if you're already doing that now
that makes me very uncomfortable about
the future direction of this
relationship you said I at least want to
be engaged I want to have all this paid
off I wanted this I wanted this and he's
like nah
if you move in with me in 18 months you
can try out for me for six months and
then I might I might uh I might get
engaged after that screw that dude I
forget that and Celeste he's also saying
uh I get the benefit of you helping
cover some of the yeah some of the
mortgage you pay my bills and you can
practice being my wife and then I'll let
you know in six or eight months uh if
you if you made the team Celeste you
wanna know if I was thinking because he
said that it would be more like I rent
this really expensive here too so he'd
be helping me out too oh how cute oh
that's what happened oh no that's what
he spun it he did a good job of selling
you on it but here's the deal you want
to find out if this dude's for you or
not
all right but here's okay but listen you
want to know I'm gonna tell you how to
know and John you correct me if this is
too intense but I I think I got it
here's what I would do I'd say you know
what I thought about this
and
I initially asked you to put a ring on
it before we got into this decision
I don't feel comfortable with what you
came back with because there's so many
risks you can quote some of the stuff
that John said go get your own data and
just say whatever you want to do and
then I'd say okay I'm gonna go a step
further though
I'm going to take advantage of the offer
that my mom and dad have made for me and
I'm not going to move in with you until
we get married
okay okay and then just stop
just stop like ultimatum no no no no no
no not an ultimatum this is what I want
to do if he hears it as an ultimatum and
runs that's on him that's where I'm
going with this I think he's going to
reveal pretty quickly how much he wants
you in his life because to John's point
this dude's got all kinds of conditions
that honestly
all benefit him
oh wow okay okay he's got a live-in
girlfriend who pays half his rent he
wins we we win this is friends with
benefits I think that much about it and
you helped pay down his mortgage and
then y'all break up and oh all right and
by the way I've got I've got several
friends that I've known since I was Zero
okay we were like toddlers together I've
got several folks that I know from
middle school
and they are dramatically different
people when they were 22 than they were
when they were 11. and they're super
different now that they're in their 40s
both good and both whoa
so just because you got a history
doesn't mean it's always right and now
yeah I want you to also take this Ken
and I are are pushing on you I'm not
telling you to go dump him today that's
something that's a decision you got to
own you can't call them and be like hey
these two clowns on the radio told us
and that's on you that's right but we're
trying to say
we both have daughters we both got wives
we both got colleagues here and great
friends who are strong professional
women listen
I I don't like someone blowing your
needs off just being like ah this is how
we're gonna do this you're worth more
than that yeah and listen uh Echo what
John said so let's listen to me we're
not saying dump him I'm saying give him
an alternative Vision if you believe in
that and I just told you what I would
say you may say all right I'm gonna wait
until the rings on the finger but I got
to tell you I want to see that this dude
is committed to me I'll just give you
one other opinion that's based in
experience yes please I'm gonna hit 25
years of marriage in May okay wow thank
you I'm not saying that to to get the
congratulations I'm telling you what
John said Is Right
Stacy and I will celebrate that
milestone
not because we're great husbands and
wives all the time not because we've got
a quarter you're not going to see a
marriage book coming from Ken and Stacy
Coleman
but we made it because we committed it
was all in if Stacy had said I want to
wait to move in I would have said you
got it because I wanted to marry Stacy
I still want to be married to Stacy I
want to stay married to Stacy that's why
I've done all kinds of things and John's
right I got married at 23. I'm not the
same guy thank God that I was when I'm
23. but I also got a woman that's walked
through that Journey with me we've
gotten better as individuals we've
gotten better in our marriage and we've
had some tough times and and really
excruciating pain that we've had to walk
through together all I'm saying is we
need to know if this guy is all in for
the future and if he is it's not an
ultimatum you're giving him it is what
you believe is right for you okay in
relation to us and we're going to find
out real quick is he in it for the
benefits or is he in it for Celeste and
listen uh last piece of little wisdom
before we hang up on you
under no circumstances if you do move in
with him knock your lights out do not
co-sign on a mortgage together until
you're married it creates a whole big
legal mess don't do it don't do it don't
do it
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm Ken
Coleman joined by Dr John deloney we're
here for you this hour triple eight
eight two five five two two five taking
your money questions your work questions
your relationship questions mental
health all of that stuff John and I
together let's combo up for you however
we can triple eight eight two five five
two two five now before we get back to
the phones John
uh you've got a very interesting story
that I think has uh some very very
relevant cultural application here what
do you got so it's Seattle schools suing
Tick Tock meta and other platforms over
the youth Mental Health crisis this is
out of uh Yahoo finance
the article goes on to say Seattle
public schools have sued the tech Giants
Behind these programs Tick Tock Facebook
Instagram YouTube and Snapchat accusing
them of creating a mental health crisis
among America America's youth the
91-page lawsuit suggests they understand
and know and then exploit The Addictive
nature of social media leading to
Horizon anxiety depression and thoughts
of self-harm
um okay your honor if I put one of those
old powdered wigs on you and the black
robe and you're behind the big desk do
you accept this lawsuit or do you reject
it just on Merit alone just on what
you've read so under my understanding of
what they know about the addictive
nature of their platforms and how they
work and particularly the way especially
tick tock's algorithms are especially
designed to capture kids
um yeah I would accept it absolutely
where this in in the the road map for
this legal case was made with cigarettes
right like so people are all going to
follow that blueprint right you all knew
this was addictive you knew it was
killing people and you put that that
that research in a drawer and you kept
telling everybody it was fine
that's the path here's where this feels
a little bit different to me this is a
very much a both and I've got no problem
with people taking on these big big
companies that are are taking over our
kids Minds
but parents have got to step up like you
you can't
I can't hand my kid a device to the
universe
and then get mad that people on the
other end of that like it doesn't like
all these devices have off buttons all
of them they all do and so if your kid
is addicted to
Tick Tock meta other platforms turn it
off smash the phones throw dig a hole
and bury them do something with them but
moms and dads have got to reclaim their
minds of their kids
um and I understand people got to travel
and drive and I know that I'm a Luddite
when it comes to some of that stuff and
there is a balance there and there's
some emerging technology that allows for
this kind of phone to just allow you to
text Mom oh I get all that all the
arguments
what most of this comes down to and I
felt it myself is
every other kid is doing it too and I
want to encourage parents be the only
one be the only one in your friend group
whose kids don't have a Facebook account
or a meta account are and are living in
the real world not in metaverse nonsense
crap on a stick like I I it it's
infuriating to me at that level and some
somebody's got to take these guys on
because what does it say here we've have
invested heavily in creating safe
experiences for children I love that
um and dedicated features to prioritize
their well-being this is a tick tock
statement this is a Google statement oh
Google where I would challenge them is
they have they've done some great things
trying to police uh child pornography
they've done some great things trying to
police
um sex trafficking
to say they are trying to make their
platforms less addictive unless keeping
kids glued to them is patently false and
so they're taking one thing they're
doing over here and trying to broadly
apply it across their case it's nonsense
nonsense I want to take this another
step because I it's been reported so I
want to be very careful here sure I'm
not saying this is fact but it has been
widely reported that the Chinese version
of tick tock is different is math and
science related right it is not all the
pop culture and the entertainment right
if that's true
Ed has to be a warning sign
right well and it's why is that the case
well if you've got it I mean if you've
got another country
fiddling with the uh algorithm that
tells our kids
look how great achievements of math and
science are this is what gets kids
excited this is what Riley's around we
all know the the research we want to be
like our peers right right and if you
move the algorithm over here that
suggests hey the next dance is the craze
look what all the kids are doing that's
where kids are going to go you could
take over a country's kids without ever
firing a shot you can just make
everything flashy I think I hear what
you're saying and put on the right music
and We're Off to the Races and I I
completely think that's what's going on
I mean this is this is bigger than just
parenting right
it's big big multi-multi-billion billion
billion billions of dollars and that's
that's that's the and let's be honest I
try to I I have an Instagram account
right and I if if it went away tomorrow
okay yeah you know what I mean oh
completely agree I mean like we got the
the team's trying to get me to do more
over here I'm I'm sure like adopting it
because again I didn't grow up with that
as the norm right and so now we've
gotten to a place where this is all the
norm so okay let's say they successful
in shutting down Tick Tock what's the
next Snapchat what's the next Instagram
what's the next thing it's not a
surprise that questions for humans
turned into a million dollar project
because
people are having a conversation for the
first time and it feels right their
bodies are settling in and going I just
experienced 30 minutes of eye contact
with my seven-year-old and I didn't know
that was possible that's right and it
feels right my granddad just talked to
my 14 year old son and my 14 year old
son's face is always buried in his iPad
and they just had a long conversation
I like how this feels right and so I
think eventually they shut some of this
nonsense down or I can't figure out a
way to make this healthy and so you shut
it down then people are gonna have to
look at each other in the eye and say I
I guess you want to go out and play
basketball you kick soccer ball all
right you play Dungeons and Dragons I
don't care what it is but we're gonna
sit on a table and look at each other
and talk yeah by the way the questions
for humans cards available at
ramseysolutions.com or John deloney.com
but
if you look at the cigarette
application which I think you're right
like when they went after the tobacco
companies
I don't have the numbers in front of me
but I don't know if the usage or the
sales of cigarettes went down up I don't
think it was a big
I don't know so do you actually shut a
tick tock down uh a social media giant
down with a lawsuit I don't know uh yeah
that's that's beyond my pay grade I just
I just know that I guess it makes sense
that they're going after him at the same
time
I I'm tired of us as a culture getting
mad at other people for not teaching our
kids things that we should be teaching
at home that's the issue I agree 100
there's personal responsibility like
when people come after me like I don't
want them teaching that stuff about if I
Outsource spirituality to my local
school yeah or to my private school I'm
failing my kids that's my job if I
Outsource
um connectivity if I Outsource love if I
Outsource well-being to a school I'm
failing them if I'm Outsourcing you need
to protect what's going in my kid's head
schools go fight that battle for me I'm
failing my kids that's my job yeah right
to take some ownership over that yeah
and I'm I'm just ready for parents to
step back up and not in a dramatic way
we see on Instagram where everyone's
like I'm fighting at the school board no
I'm talking about being honest with your
kids I mean open with your kids I mean
connecting with your kids that's a
totally different
um way of being man well and and
honestly if we you know we got a lot of
young parents that are listening and
watching the show
if long before social media gets
involved it's the devices themselves
right I mean come on yeah it's a
babysitter at the restaurant it's it's
they call them they call them the
digital babysitters man you know and I I
want to ask this I know this is a deep
Rabbit Hole we're not going to go down
how much longer how many more years
before we see some substantive research
that tells us should we be alarmed about
all the device usage or is it not that
big a deal uh Dr Tia Peter Tia had a an
excellent
um discussion of an article that came
out recently some good research that
suggests someone like me who's always
raising the alarms I may I'm probably
misguided that a kid in front of a
screen is not the end of time
um I I liken that too giving your kid a
couple of chocolate chip cookies every
day it's not going to kill you it's
there's no harm in that
but that often gives people license to
just give their kids 70 a day and that
does have a long-term effect on your kid
I think it's very similar if you're a
parent that has the discipline to say
I'm gonna watch this with you we're
going to discuss it when it's over then
screens can actually lead to
connectivity
if it's a digital babysitter and you
just want an hour of Peace which God
help me I got two young kids I get that
man so much so much I'm just gonna stick
him in front of a screen so that I can
breathe and stare off into space or that
I can scroll my Instagram now you got a
problem yeah interesting stuff all right
we'll see what the future holds around
all this stuff thank you guys so much
for listening in and watching we're not
going anywhere coming up more of your
calls he's John deloney I'm Ken Coleman
this is the Ramsey Ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsey show this is
where we talk to you about your life and
your money your relationships your
mental health your work all so that you
can walk forward with Clarity and
confidence to live the life that you
desire to live we're here for you I'm
Ken Coleman he is Dr John deloney the
phone number is triple eight eight two
five five two two five Brianna is up
next in Hattiesburg Mississippi Brianna
how can we help
sir I just started the baby stuff
[Music]
I was wondering if it would be possible
to start a non-profit in the next four
years I have two thousand six hundred
dollars in debt and I'm planning to pay
that off in the next six months
you guys had any advice on that you have
two thousand six hundred dollars in debt
yes sir why is that gonna take you six
months to pay off
um because
I'm I need to rework my payment plan but
I have originally planned to pay off a
hundred dollars a week
but now since I've been on your guys's
show I'm just gonna throw my money at it
but where do you work
I work at a Keith Superstore it's a gas
station okay and so I'm at part time I'm
planning to go to college in the next
hopefully next spring or next fall
for business management because
um I feel like my life calling is to
help people who have lost their parents
and stuff awesome because that's a
beautiful calling I here's what I want
you to do though I want you to get a
second and a third job
and work like a maniac and be done with
this in 30 days
and I'm not even playing and that might
sound like you might be like you're an
idiot I'm telling you no you can
scrounge and work and get on Uber Eats
tonight and start delivering do whatever
you have to do get this thing out of
your life in 30 days and be done and you
are going to walk six inches taller
okay be free of this and prove to
yourself I can do anything in 30 days
is that fair
that's fair what are you making per hour
right now Brianna
um nine dollars yeah I gotta tell you I
love John's advice because I want you
looking around Hattiesburg for hourly
jobs I don't care what it is it's full
time I mean I want you making 15 an hour
what what what needs to be true for you
to make 18 to 20 an hour in Hattiesburg
that's the question I want you to answer
yes here's what happens
what John told you is right whether it's
another job two more jobs or a better
paying job you walk these baby steps out
before you know it you've got three to
six months of expenses in the bank
and now we look at our future very
differently and I want to challenge you
on something really quick
um what the non-profit that you want to
start
how will you engage with people who've
lost their parents what is that what is
that gonna look like
through Word of Mouth mainly and I've
already created a Facebook page for it
to start together people because I know
there's several support groups on
Facebook that people follow
and I really want to reach out to these
people and mainly I'm focusing on the
parents and their kids because I lost my
mom when I was 11 to cancer and there
was no community that my dad nor I could
reach out to to talk about this stuff
and I was inspired by the Mississippi
diabetes Foundation because they have an
awesome they have a two-day camp for
kids they have a wheat camp and so
that's eventually what I want it to look
like great okay so here's what I want
you to do so all the money advice John
gave and that we've given you here on
making more money and getting getting
yourself stable is great but I I want
you to press pause on going to school I
didn't say not go to school but I want
you to press pause until
you can start
volunteering at the least working as a
second or third job at the most for
local non-profits that are doing this
kind of stuff and providing support in
communities maybe summer camps you know
if you can kind of structure your world
and maybe you work in an evening job in
the summer so that you're not gonna have
a lot of sleep but a one week of Camp a
year at a minimum or you're working in
these camps and you're getting paid to
observe and and see how they're engaging
and it's going to further crystallize
your vision for the future and I want
you to get
aware of the world that you want to get
into to the point where you can decide
do I need a business management degree
or do I need to just start working for
some non-profits and and learn
everything I can about running a
non-profit
and get involved build a community from
the ground up in your ZIP code before we
decide to start this in four years I I I
want to encourage you I don't want you
to be discouraged at all with what I
said but do you understand what I'm
saying will allow you to have a better
vision and not feel this pressure to
launch this thing in four years you
understand what I'm saying yes sir I
understand and that's actually great
advice because I learned more Hands-On
than I do from Reading anyway yeah and I
actually think what's going to happen in
two or three years you're not business
management might not make as much sense
as getting a therapy degree or a
counseling degree or a social work
degree and learning the skills to sit
with people who are hurting and then
learn how to teach other people those
skills so running in and getting a
business management degree May
it may cap your growth in a little bit
you have to go hire a therapist if for a
lot of money for your new nonprofit all
that to say is Ken's right take some
time okay take some time
um I really want to see you have a
full-time job
and a side job on top of that I want you
and by the way working a non-profit
those people work really really really
hard for not a lot so I want you to
start practicing working really really
really hard okay
um yes sir get this debt out of there
get yourself 10 or 15 000 in the bank
and then you've got some leverage to
decide I want to go to college what I
want to do next I think that'd be
fantastic good for you okay yeah proud
of you you got a great heart you're
gonna do great things Brianna thank you
so much for calling Nathan is up next in
Colorado Springs Colorado Nathan how can
we help
hi uh so I have 300 000 in debt and how
much I go to 300 000. oh boy are you a
doctor where are the Tums no so a lot of
it comes from my uh wife's uh College
choices that she made
um but the question that I have is I
have three cars in the next year and a
half I'll be going to Germany and I can
only take one car
I don't know what to do with the three
cars should I sell all three cars and
buy a cheap car and hopefully it turns
out for the good it runs good for all
three years or should I
well you need a car in Germany
yes for work why
uh just to get from home to work
they have an Exquisite public transit
system I was gonna say I'm gonna
challenge that have you done your
homework on that
a little bit not a lot do a lot more
sell all three cars absolutely all three
the the pay the cost it's gonna cost you
a couple of Grand at a minimum to even
get it over there isn't it
uh no it'll be paid for by my uh job
what do you owe on the cars start with
Logistics you pick them car one car two
car three what do you owe uh uh car one
I owe 22 it's worth 26 car two I owe 35
it's worth 18 and car three I own
outright since I can probably sell for
six to eight so you're upside down big
time in car two
correct
what kind of car is it
it's a 2022 Ford Escape how much is the
car worth that you own outright
um about six to ten
okay well John's right I definitely am
selling the car that you owe 22 on today
I'm listing it tonight and hopefully we
get 26 for it so now you got 4 000 there
and you got to put all four thousand of
that uh on the car that you owe 35 on
you're still upside down and you know at
that point how are you upside down that
much with this wonkiest car prices have
been
I made a bad decision turned it in a car
for a kid in a truck I rolled a bunch of
equity in
yes
oh man
okay
yikes
uh okay so this is gonna be just one of
those moments man how old are you
28. Dave used to call it stupid tax I
won't call it that but I'll just say
this is this is going to be a real
expensive
um
smack upside the head and you'll know to
never ever do this again right
correct yeah right if I here's the deal
if I'm you I'm selling every car I got
and it's a cool that my company has this
perk but we don't have to we don't have
to utilize every perk it's like going to
a store and buying something just
because it's on sale you don't have to
do that I'd sell all these three I'd go
to Germany try to use the public transit
system and if I have to get a car then
I'll buy a local car used there but I'm
not traveling with a six thousand dollar
car overseas that just seems silly
um and I'd sell them and y'all are broke
man you got to get this stuff paid off
ASAP
thank you for the call Nathan hang on
the line we're gonna get you some great
resources uh from our team Total Money
Makeover and some more Hang On the Line
This is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm Ken
Coleman I'm joined by my colleague Dr
John deloney we're here for you this
hour triple eight eight two five five
two two five our scripture of the day
comes from second chronicles 15 7. but
as for you be strong and do not give up
for your work will be rewarded our quote
of the day comes from the goat
I'm just going to say it
it's not LeBron James it's Michael
Jordan and I meant it when I said it
obstacles don't have to stop you if you
run into a wall don't turn around and
give up figure out how to climb it go
through it or work around it even his
quotes are better than LeBron
I mean what do you want I'm tired I got
a 14 year old kid who won't even
acknowledge that Jordan could be the
goat I've seen them both play it's not
up for a vote I'm all about Hakeem
Olajuwon man okay there's another one
fantastic uh that'll get me some hate
mail that statement alone yeah I hope
they clip that and put that on the uh on
the tick tocks I'll be huge
I'll blow up uh let's go to Brandon who
joins us now in Raleigh North Carolina
Brandon how can we help hey yes sir so
um hope y'all are doing good by the way
as well oh we're doing great thank you
I've been with my job now for about 11
or 12 years I've got good retirement
good pay uh benefits and all that stuff
um kind of getting bored with it and I
don't know if I should make a career
change or not because I don't know what
to really get into I want I thought
about flight attendants but I'm not sure
that I will be good at it or won't do
I'm not sure so I'm having a hard time
deciding what to do and if I should just
kind of sell everything I've got and
make a career change and move if I need
to or well what's your current job yeah
I mean let's let's slow down I like what
you've done what are you doing now that
is that is causing you to be bored so I
work for the county that I live in
locating Water and Sewer lives
and that's pretty much all I do is uh
When contractors call I just go out
there and Mark our stuff so they don't
hit it while they're digging I think you
might be the first person in human
history to go from locating sewer lines
to flight attendants I I know I'm
passing out peanuts You've Won dealing
with idiots like me like my back hurts
and my knees are like whatever dude
you just made my whole day man so here's
the question uh what made you come up
and by the way I don't want you to doubt
this I just want you to tell me what's
behind the idea of being a flight
attendant where'd that come from there's
a reason why that pops in your mind what
is it I I just think flying is cool and
traveling and stuff
um and it's just a change I don't know I
kind of I used to well throughout my
whole high school year I worked at a
restaurant so I waited tables and stuff
like that so I don't mind waiting on
people and helping people and serving
people and stuff like that okay now
there all right so let's lock in on that
for a moment and here's the deal my
advice on the flight attendant is I
wrote about I wrote an entire book on
this called the proximity principle and
it simply says this in order to do what
Brandon wants to do he's got to be
around people that are doing it and in
places where it's happening this is also
about confirmation you need to actually
talk to some people who are flight
attendants so I think one of your
homework assignments is uh to through
friends of friends or family members get
on the phone or Zoom or lunch or coffee
with somebody you live in Raleigh so
that's a hub for Southwest there's got
to be a way that you can meet with
somebody and just talk to them you
remember doing a term paper back in high
school you know about okay what is
involved in this career just ask all the
questions I want to know the highs I
want to know the lows what is does it
take to get qualified what do you make
what does promotion look like what's
that Journey what's the most like I mean
you need to know more it can't just be I
like flying I like traveling now that's
the homework assignment on the flight
attendant thing but I want to go back
into you have been in the service
industry before
and you said I didn't mind waiting on
people but I'm curious to know what kind
of work forget about job title do you
think about because when your mind
wanders I mean do you really love
caretaking taking care of people and
serving people or is there a different
kind of work that you've always kind of
been drawn to what's the answer to that
my mind just goes a thousand miles an
hour I think about
going into cutting grass full time maybe
switching to a different government job
but real estate all kinds of Brandon
what are you and you're thinking Brandon
what are you running from man
I I don't know nothing really yes you
are why don't you like your life
because all I did I go to work I come
home and I'm single no wife no kids
nothing like that so I literally I go
work come home and do nothing except for
just hang out at the house or I go out
on my motorcycle or something like that
but the main thing is just boredom I'm
just tired of sitting around the house
yes so here's the deal John's right
there there's some stuff going on here
but I want to take you back there was a
season there was a time it may have been
two weeks ago it may have been last
night I don't mean thinking of all these
different ideas where you can go work
and get a paycheck I'm saying what do
you wonder about
in the dark of night if I could do this
it feels like a unicorn to you it feels
like that dream fantasy it's way far out
there I could never do it I want to know
the thing that you've wondered about
the type of work that you go I would
love to do that if I could just snap my
fingers I would do this and I think you
have an answer
uh
you're already thinking about it yes you
do I've done this enough what is it real
estate I would say that's probably been
on my mind the most probably all right
what about real estate connects to some
of the moments in your past work life
that you've enjoyed I want you to think
about all the time that you've worked a
lot of different things there have been
moments where you've had enjoyment you
felt like I was making a difference here
and I and it made me stand up a little
straighter
and connect those moments to real estate
what about real estate draws you in why
do you think that you would love that
get up excited about it
because I I just enjoy houses and people
and like looking at the
different how things are built different
and stuff like that great if I
interviewed everybody that knows you
Brandon and I said tell me Brandon's top
two or three people skills where he's
really good with people what would they
tell me
uh just talking and helping good John I
I see a pattern here and I think he's
looking for that role where he can see
that he's making a difference in
people's lives and instead of trying to
come up with all the ideas I think it's
connecting to the people that he most
wants to help and being okay with that
answer what do you think yeah
Brandon before you jump ship on your job
as kinseka as you start thinking about
what is this going to look like what am
I going to do
I want you to look at your life and
start doing things differently even when
it feels weird
what I mean by that is stop going
straight home and just turn on the TV
and crack in a beer and plopping your
feet up and then wait until the day's
over she can get up and do it again the
next day and don't just go on Saturday
mornings and put your helmet on and
drive your motorcycle around by yourself
you've created a lonely existence for
yourself I'd much rather you see grab a
couple of guys and say Hey Monday nights
we go out to wherever and we throw darts
we play cards
um whatever we do and start creating
opportunities for you to hang out with
people and create opportunities for your
life to be different that's going to
give you some clarity on what comes next
with your work and let me add one thing
what John said I want you to find in
your ZIP code the area where you
frequent
find some people that have got some
needs that you have something to offer
and why don't you go do that
instead of going home like John said why
don't you go volunteer one or two nights
over the next couple days go do
something yes that you're able to do for
somebody some way of service I think you
need to get the juice back this idea of
hey I'm making a difference I I'm doing
something that put a smile on somebody's
face I helped an old lady no one else
would help
even if it's not if you can't find
service opportunities in your community
go uh which you can in Russia for sure
yeah go get a second gig two nights a
week wait in tables they'd be happy to
have you these days man they're
desperate for help but go put yourself
in a position to be around other people
man but to do something fun like John
saying it's got to be work that you
enjoy yes hang on the line we're gonna
send you uh the get clear assessment
Ken's assessment so you can start asking
yourself okay what is the life after
locating sewer lines and I'm gonna send
you questions for humans um guys night
out uh oh I love that whatever the else
they got so you can take these out and
hang out with some people and say hey I
got this stuff from this idiot on the
radio let's try these cards out and it
will at least facilitate some
conversation yeah man have some fun with
some people Brandon you got a lot to
offer man you're a bright like I want to
hang out with you Brandon he's like a
cool guy absolutely come to Nashville
we'll get you some hot chicken and then
talk about it hey John deloney good hour
thank you sir I want to thank James the
entire crew for keeping us on the air
want to thank you America for listening
this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
hey it's Ken if you like what you heard
in this episode and want to know more
about getting started on the Ramsey Baby
Steps go to ramsesolutions.com and click
on the get started button we'll help you
figure out the best next step for you
based on your specific situation again
that's ramseysolutions.com and click get
started
[Music]